لن يبدو دخول العام الجديد كما هو
تمامًا هذا العام ، حيث
يحتفل معظمنا من المنزل ،
وهذا يترك سؤالًا واحدًا هل يجب
أن نرتدي ملابسنا تمامًا حتى لو
كنا نحتفل بالأعياد
تقريبًا مثل لماذا لم نكن  في
المنزل
مرتديًا بنطلونات رياضية وملابس الركض
خلال الأشهر التسعة الماضية ، أعتقد أننا
نريد أن ننتهز هذه
الفرصة للتنقيب في خزانات الملابس الخاصة بنا ، وسحب
شيئًا
احتفاليًا سواء كان ذلك لعيد الميلاد
أو ليلة رأس السنة
، وبعض الإكسسوارات وضعت على بعض
الأقراط وتبدو رائعة  يقول
ستيفن وتارا دان ، خبير الموضة للزوج والزوجة ، إنهما
لا تنظران إلى أبعد من خزانة ملابسك الخاصة
التي تبدو رائعة على الكتفين
لكل فئة عمرية
لأن الكتفين لا يشيخون أبدًا ، لذا
بغض النظر عن
عمرك ، دائمًا ما يكون مثيرًا ومثيرًا في الموضة
وإذا  ليس لديك سترة خارج الكتف ،
اذهب إلى الخزانة ، ابحث عن السترة ،
اسحبها لأسفل على الكتف ،
يمكنك سحبها فوق كرسي والسماح لها
بالتمدد وهناك  قم بتجربة
الجزء العلوي من الكتف للحصول على آذان جديدة
وأنت لا تكسر
الترتر فهو رائع يجعلك تشعر بالرضا
لأنه يضيء
مزاجك وهو بالتأكيد شيء
إذا كان لديك في خزانتك ، يجب عليك
سحبه
لأنك تريده مرة أخرى
شيء يشعرك به وتبدو جميلًا
هذا الموسم
خاصةً بداية عام جديد مشرق للغاية
وصدق أو لا تصدق ذلك البلوزة القديمة
التي يجب أن تخرجها من الخزانة
أيضًا ،
لقد صنعنا الكثير من البلوزات المزخرفة
هذا العام أه مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
أننا  ستبقى في المنزل خلال
العطلات ، لكن يمكنك تزيين سترتك الخاصة
بالاستيلاء على بعض منصات الكتف وبعض
الترتر ربما المعلقات القديمة التي لديك
في المنزل ، ربما بعض الخرزات وتصبح مبدعة حقًا
وتستمتع بملابس النوم التي قد
تحل محل ذلك القليل  قد يكون الفستان الأسود
البيجامة الحريرية هذا العام للعام
الجديد هو ربطة العنق السوداء للعام الجديد الخاص بك.
كان مثل الزي الرسمي
لكننا سنحب
أن نرتدي البيجامة الحريرية لها وله